I'm sorry he what welcome to this video
playing grandma's a cheetah with black
no name but a very high rating 25
something played him once and lost okay
Jess I'll get to get the bow go on maybe
this one something else check okay he's
allowing this line which is generally
considered to be quite good for black
Quincy one Jack came you can do that
with King f1 interesting
yeah 93 m this is possible I think they
go d5 now not totally sure this is not
one of my frequent lines okay so yeah
just back to e7 I guess and then
castling yeah it looks like a fairly
normal position the only thing out of
the ordinary is that he has not
cancelled king is on everyone try for
Bishop before okay so crook da don how
do i play this rook e8 k III as a movie
will play anyway interesting
when knight on c6 this is not really
great I wonder how to regroup the night
and maybe going to d6 would have been
better have to cover that first yeah
well it took far too a long time here
for 97 90 x 90 x 90 755 FB 6 yeah so I'm
not losing material repair the ship t 5
p-6 so I will whoops twice as possible
that's weird
Jeff okay
look f8 or not not so that insert this
check which is not bad then go for this
getting this over to be 7 to attack f3
that's a good spot is angling for your
form let's see if I can get near
skinnier night should go to f4 somehow
if possible routes have night b5 as a as
a move to check his pawn yep he
prevented that i'm off to g6 oh i'm
giving away c7 now if i do that okay I'm
taking this
so let's jump right in for Knight takes
e4 e5 94 check check so look f3 no g5 is
right here taking away those squares
that's important now how can I can I
check medium somehow rook f2 is no maid
unfortunately rock gee tong check
so I'm threatening Bishop g5 maybe for
Luke g2 and rook f1 here is 7s very
quick unfortunately Butchie talking
every Rock g1 just a bunch of checks
time warning I don't see a winner and
fortunately he dont je I didn't see a
win Jeff fortunately really what a shame
Kim
ah quite quite a shame Jeff it's a draw
at least I mean time wise it's tricky
but Jan why shouldn't one that gras oh
ok ok game yeah thanks for not trying
that Jay of course it was at all
children but I I screwed it up let's
check their how could have i mean this
is a weird blunder because b6 was kind
of I'm not just giving away the pond
there ok Angie I'm winning but I screwed
it up let's see i mean i think i'm
pretty ok for most of that but the
interesting moment is is here when I
really should have a win but I didn't
find it the ship f three years good ok
and this wasn't still be sugar three no
I didn't think about that move at all
rook eight to f6 is made ah no of course
I totally forgot about that i actually i
briefly considered but i didn't
understand of course still he cannot
take the bishop and I'm threatening Luke
g2 Luke h6 made so I had a major and hey
it really looked like there should be
one but I didn't see it I did not see
that ah what a how long yeah that would
have been nice the way it went it was a
draw but it was poor tense okay well
thanks for watching